yeah welcome to this video and I finally
made it to play a war zone final it's
seven seconds to go it's one hour
tournament two-minute games and let's
see how it is going going start hmm that
should start right now but somehow it
doesn't it okay we have 42 participants
at the moment or someone dropped out
okay in the route 40 and with pretty
high average rating to 126 somehow on
games doesn't game style start not quite
sure what is so what is going on I
played them now we start I guessed we
some pretty pretty good play out first
game yeah get rid of this this window
playing a solid set up his own good
tactical plan
and stuff like the Kings gambit intense
and similar openings so I'm going for
this end game heavy opening I'm not
intending to to play for a draw yet
maybe look rather timid but I just want
to play an old game and try to outplay
my goal is to make his pieces look bad
the the bishop in particular so it's
trying to exchange everything but this
doesn't necessarily need to draw I have
everything on dark squares hmm
k how tuned first I need to get this
Bishop into the game
you know this is something I don't mind
oops oh I would have gotten a protected
urban and the some distant past porn
anyway so I'm both better anyway but not
that better ok next one internal it's
yeah as usual I'm trying to play just
normal normal moves I simply cannot play
those wacky gambit openings simply spent
far too much time if I play that also I
always ask myself why exactly am I one
or two points down and then it doesn't
help me I'd rather play stuff like that
and have a better ending and win it it
it takes somewhat longer but it's just
um
fits my style of playing Latin so I can
take a five now right oh I cannot lies
got be sure to successful city otherwise
this would be nice I forgot about I
forgot about there should be six really
okay well i started still not not so
clear but this wasn't wasn't really what
I intended
there are still
I have some activity
gotten quite a number of points now
yeah okay this is just winning so far
too many points
mmm not the not exactly great how I
played this hmm
yeah this is winning again now but this
was very very very young very bad plane
yeah they just promote
only avoid the stalemate
okay this wasn't great but at least I'm
among them the leaders king Oh form okay
got a classical French oh okay
yeah this wasn't exactly a refutation I
could have taken on you five taking on
you five and grab are no exception t5
b-52 all so close though okay maybe i
can i can irritate them a bit with this
no not really this didn't play any any
bad move
how to continue here and get rid of the
the night champ it's not great great it
on and it's playing good moves Bishop
before looks like a good mood okay maybe
I can now make some progress here
activating this is only gave me the F up
on this was generous and thus he cannot
even protect with c3 is a pin
yeah let's check in on the c4
yeah take take everything so usually a
good recipe
oh this is actually helpful getting one
rogue off their communities winning
whatever is playing but so it's better
to have some stuff exchanged I could
have say taken c 3 x-ray
oops
give me give me the Queen
okay hmm
ya got 20-something seconds so so
normally should be enough
only avoid any stupid stalemates all
right so 303 God didn't play so many
games we which I want against in round
one ISA managed a couple of extra games
hope didn't want that really like a [ __ ]
not a better a bit big deal scrap this
this Bishop
ok
you're just playing solid stuff
got the slightly better pawn structure
oh just gave away h2 I didn't really
didn't really notice that it was hanging
I could take b3 how ridiculous is that
mmm yeah well maybe I sure you've come
to eat too I will see that ah now what
nonsense anyway to do to defend the
scrap don't really know yeah why it's
lost anyway i hope to maybe you can play
Queenie 5 get the Queen's off or
something
yeah this is not the worst possible
outcome really I'm not mated disposed
this for certainly a real really
possible the team came trying to get
this
trying to get some some of the pawns
you have down to 20 seconds this is this
is bad
Oh
of course not 25 okay this was so stupid
allowing the the exchange this is so
easy now it's like impossible to to
screw it up really
yeah now this was very bad after i
blundered h2 didn't really pay attention
that you attacked us I don't want to
draw I want to double it ah what's this
was silly yeah I wanted to double of
course not to draw against someone okay
so on let's start this game I need to
win not a drawn and now this is taking
ages
great
yeah nothing I can do this this game is
not starting so how long am i waiting so
now another game
yes played before which looks like yeah
very non developing so I try to refute
it down directly yeah okay take your
voice playing what I don't know what
usually two or something looks like
complete this is a rope daddy I take it
okay so I'm still on clays form despite
a game not starting and exit
accidentally drawing no of course not
this was a cool miss click flicked on
this instead of the the doubling button
wrong the bishop is making quite some
cool maneuvers
there's no way to he cannot win
something with clean air five it's
Bishop g2 and it's just trapped yeah got
this one oh no i'd take it okay so place
to need more of those really quick games
yeah see success and always playable pre
more
they are the Braunstein Lazlo had quite
quite good results with this in in five
minute games blitz games people really
have some problems on 95 I saw that crap
not exactly difficult to see I admit it
hmm this is byssus
very stupid
yeah I'm very bad position it's not just
a pawn it's just just a total mess here
okay I take this with me maybe I'm
busted with rookie one or something so
certainly possible
you calculated all that nice okay
not bad
yeah because I mean really good okay
amazing good good good calculation by
the sky
No
ok some we had they known each type of
opening try to get the pieces actively
placed here maybe castling long or H 495
this is actually dangerous
my chief I this is really a threat now
and what
Knight f6 and queen age seven is really
really much now no way really to prevent
it it doesn't even ever check him Queen
h7s just just comes can i pre move it
yeah could you remove it that even okay
second place but I'm losing a bit bit
too many games oh no yeah this guy with
rookie set also quite nice i hope i get
him again free wrench time okay let's
let's do this again but such a bad
opening
okay I got lots of stuff on the the
light squares here nice nice night here
I'm anchoring this night so he needs to
weaken himself even though to get rid of
this so how to continue the the point
that I need to attack us be too so hmm
should I take it the night is I get to
f5 I can like and do it
I must make sure that the night gets dr5
and this is this is working so here we
go and now the the bee to pollen is the
target
no tricks no trick no trick maybe go
here maybe I have guts I push I can push
the pawns actually this is good enough
winning winning stuff now deform
and when you form everything falls apart
so ok let's go a phone maybe I can get
some quicker game in a classical French
or the stein it's French
I actually have taken with the pond or
silly it's a bit bit a bit better to
take with the porn and these kind of
positions to control the foursquare
right so still okay for white but I
don't have anything special
k defended this really well don't don't
really have any no no draw but I don't
have don't have a good idea really how
to how to proceed him
hmm
no idea
so he's very solid
you
ok maybe now H fine i can take on f7
this one was helpful oh so you can give
me the rope here it's just to check on
edge form
no mate
it is a mate okay submit the lead
actually having played the most games
there may be because of this this is a
sick draw that I that I played okay I'm
playing this again this guy really
spanked me in first game ok now he's
playing some something else
hmm yeah he's playing all this
theoretical moves quite quite
interesting
I had this just recently in a blitz game
this is why I'm playing playing this so
quickly I just need to rapid use what I
played before so take care
five or not mmm come on me five
trying to
get to get this this out the pieces
I appreciative I'd was pinned okay I
thought I mr. Bishop to to have five hmm
I cannot believe this what is this guy
doing here rupee a droopy one now and I
have no move or what unbelievable
crazy crazy okay this isn't this isn't
great but the alternatives were even
worse
is that this game is hard for me to
believe what what he's doing here
mckerrod sometimes they just play
perfect moves for whatever reason
trying to to get them get active here
it takes a silky one made how does it
prevent it now ruchi seven them oops he
simply ignored this what is happening
okay one on time yeah it was a spooky
game okay see it's got 11 out of 11 this
is not bad can't be getting some guy
from Finland and maybe this is not the
quickest way to proceed yeah trying to
still play normal openings
yeah maybe this isn't the best way to do
it it's possible but I've won a ton of
those with just normal chest and not
just sacrificing everything at hope for
the best you have threatening me five
that is that this is even Wow what
shouldn't be working take now and take
on settle this should be some extra
material
can you pick really f6 I don't know okay
this one's a quick one the chaplain
Corps let's see what this guy is doing
is sacrificing a pond so probably
probably not a little sacrifice but no
no it is actually I keep I keep the keep
the porn it's not easy to play them and
then blitz chess
no this is nice now the team that he
opened the p7 non-diagonal father for
the bishop taking c3 and d3 now to take
there and play Bishop g5 how does it
protect III not at all
and it did at first sight you think okay
this is just nonsense but why it still
has some chances under the Kings side
this is why I'm trying to try to stop
any any direct attacks I don't mind to
return to return them a bit of material
here it takes on a six I have queen bee
seventh tackling the night and it
doesn't really have a good square or
here this is even better he had a self
pender take before and c3 maybe or just
stroke a seven and rook okay 7s got
night before can take that hmm
just a prepare before you don't really
see him playing playing able to to
prevent that now I'm just pushing the
poem
maybe can play b5 mp5
I can take you
I can take care this should mop it up
real name oh I can take that the porn
I'm just just an idiot the end he can
take here and it's not so clear [ __ ] how
unnecessary was dead
Jesus Christ you can God look f3 I don't
believe it he takes on g7 I've quina for
though this is the only hope
haha I what the crap game what a crap
game how could I ever lose this okay oh
man book takes a 6 Jenna just a joke
okay gas was really winning like with
every move not only not the 1i I played
again yeah you need to windows I mean
it's London this guy's even leading the
tournament or place to and the view of
if you have such a gift you need to win
it okay so let's let's try to get some
quick wins and it's not not lost yet or
anything it just like i'm gifting so
many so many points yeah this is like am
be no near going terribly wrong like
Scott down just um just a terrible
position
snow no porn breaks and no activity yeah
and I'm playing a five after 96
yeah and t6 this wedge Willem kills all
set pieces on the queenside okay I'll
take it
can playing further the week squares
here be 67 everything is weakened
yeah this activates a bit but I got
again t5 it's not bad at all and cannot
really i mean rocky 7 is the problem
amongst others publicist is a big issue
yeah we'll keep one next getting all
pieces into play
yeah maybe that was something better but
this is just a good move okay don't mind
to take take pieces so just mmm yeah
okay let's let's first go here
now this should the should win way in
quincy three and i have six even I
could've could have played but my queen
g7 is impossible to prevent yeah I like
this mate meet next month yeah this guy
I just gifted the game to this first
place can I need to need to really play
play much much quicker the only way to
catch up here
it should be seven I've roots III nicely
nicely developed but it's not easy to
see how to how to win here or get
something get something going maybe i
can i can go here
and benefit from the from the week the
crank threatening 2323 playing for
Trixie are known but otherwise you take
too long ok couple of more of those
please
ok
maybe a quick open Sicilian hopes will
do i mostly know this this kind of
setups okay maybe I can take with the
Queen here well this looks nice
he needs to go all the way back this
cannot be bad for me
well they are but just just gives gives
away the g5 point want to take it with
the bishop not with the Queen
okay it's a pawn but it's not not so
easy now it's easy I almost blundered it
myself playing King be one I could have
taken the bishop actually
now this was nice i'm catching up here
just six points behind kc
okay this isn't the most solid way ever
to play but it's it's also about both
speed now I want to try to to get
something quickly here on the G farm
that there is some potential it's not
completely ridiculous
nah this isn't this is dangerous
and threatening I think d5 and deform
pushing pushing the center and if it
takes the direct threat on g2 but before
i get d 5
and so it's a good center loop g8 nh-5
coming they just here if you take that
age five of course the only thing I
don't like is that my own king is a bit
bit exposed also that's nothing nothing
I can do okay let's let's break through
him cannot be bad
hmm yeah come on keep it simple get to
the to the rook endgame where I'm a porn
up and I've got 40 seconds extra
yeah this was a bit silly i played this
if you know that you're going to win on
time I mean I really like to to play bed
stuff then no [ __ ] dammit okay
ok
yeah what can you do I'm still still
third place
now it wasn't exactly cook
and this guy isn't so bad really
t-6s m is very uncommon maybe this is
the reason I don't know
yeah I've gotten the porn back and he's
got the slightly exposed King so
probably this is all right it's a um I
cannot go to d5 him what a shame and I
can but be sure b6 I just want to get
the Queen back he needs to do something
with the five porn I'm just attacking to
take it again he has no natural way to
defend this yeah but the Sun Oh should I
take this yeah probably i should so
really destroying the structure you
should h3i go 93 want to go there anyway
and I always have g3 okay
muttering Knight f6 and 96 got d7 honey
well this was what's nice
yeah CARICOM path he's giving away this
yeah not sure what's very quick with
with taking it well might be five was a
blunder at least I hope can take g5
should i do that let's let's take it
and cannot the castle this is the
problem they try if I have covered
if I had it officially gone to a five
this can get no distance okay i think
it's could've gotten turned ugly back 24
was even better think getting the Queen
self okay but I can can go here this is
in fact helpful protecting a five and
attacking this bishop
yeah I just need Bishop f6 and Kings you
said and it's it's basically over let's
go for that I can also push the e and
push the H poor now this this Bishop is
super strong justice check right
there are lots of pins
hmm sino had no direct win so it's
really terrible looking but I but now
this is this that's it I think why does
the Queen go weds the covers h2 + f3
don't think there's a square yeah
I is continuing and it would have been
nice okay this is quick enough to have a
real quick win some guy even overtook me
Jesus how much how quickly do I need to
win they need need some some weaker
players actually or maybe some some crab
openings like this I thought I
blundering you for this is this is cool
okay I Kevin
you have just developed everything I'm
trying to get some activity now
a 94 and then we'll be h4 h5 taking on
the Kings side you have these are off
all pretty em slow wins some in case I
need to win first but I mean even if I
should win it it's really taking long
and some some quick wind was was
necessary yeah this is a very good good
position
you should perform bishop each success
and the IDM yeah don't want to but I
need to he's got still absolutely no
counter play Nyjah 54 okay let's first
kick this away
I'm trying to to use the docs quiz
night h2g for some further possibility
but take it with the Queen how does he
prevent queen of 6 he cannot wholly
cannot play Queenie son yeah CA the same
I know no way to what what are those
guys doing I mean how will how quickly
do the wind and possible
yeah maybe they win with with stuff like
that yeah just pushing stuff forward and
hoping for the best but it says it's not
a bad recipe if you if you do that and
you don't play really terrible
yeah f6 is falling but to win this it
will again take some time okay it's not
funny maybe something else d 385 no hay
yep take you three
yeah and some Nazis either technically
it's always nice to have an extra point
but it's not so not completely easy to
win
yeah it should be should be very good no
actually just a six
No
he some in his slide slides up swung
with e5 threatening
night eh son hmm
you have no choice i need to do that
No
yeah but this is the H porn it takes the
edge porn yeah this promotes quickly
enough
if you have the king and queen stop the
porn
yeah it's not so bad but they simply
hits Quinn much quicker it's actually
almost over if my clock is correct so
like over over in seconds
yeah yeah some made on each said nursi
only if it would be possibility to do it
to win it I mean in the in the given
time no maybe maybe I can do it all
rights double hane it should even with
with the Queen okay so I've got six
plays this is this is not good okay but
if I didn't have him do so badly I just
didn't get too many too many games in I
had 22 games we got 33 games and I don't
know not not too too great and then it's
a not far away in points of just 50
points behind her kissy but I didn't
didn't get any quick resign us also not
really yeah I didn't didn't play them so
so often those tournaments maybe I'm
slightly more dicey openings would help
I don't know I hope you enjoyed it it
was I was quite good yeah thanks for
watching bye